l'entreprise en pleine semaine nationale
sur les conditions de travail
midi pyrénées fait figure de l'une des
régions pilotes
cet après midi avait lieu à toulouse la
présentation du nouvel atelier du raid
azf l'ex ogn un reportage de claude
stéfan ce nouvel atelier produit 900
tonnes par jour d'urée 80% pour
l'agriculture le reste est utilisé pour
la fabrication de produits techniques
notamment la mélamine les résines urée
formol et les produits de traitement des
piscines cet atelier qui emploie 33
personnes a été mise en service en et 82
pour le personnel les conditions de
travail ont totalement changé par
rapport aux anciennes installations de
production le dossier a été mené en
concertation avec tous les partenaires
afin de bénéficier de l'aide financière
de l'agencé nationale pour
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
nous avons étudié trois axes premiers
axes la formation du personnel le
personnel pour la première fois dans
notre plateforme a suivi une formation
de cinq mois avant de démarrer l'atelier
deuxièmement la participation maximum du
personnel aux différentes soit qui ont
été effectués aussi bien pour les locaux
sociaux que pour l'atelier et
troisièmement pour les améliorations de
conditions de travail telles que les
locaux sociaux l'atelier l'ascenseur le
choix des radios le choix de la
sonorisation etc etc
les grandes nouveautés dans cette unité
de production durée d'abord un local
insonorisé climatisés dans les anciens
ateliers le bruit s'élever aux environs
de 85 décibels
il a été ramené à 50 décibels atmosphère
feutrée dans la salle de commande ou la
conduite des opérations et réalisé par
un système de régulation à
microprocesseur sur consoles avec ces
nouvelles installations
le personnel ne travaille plus dans des
bâtiments où l'air ambiant était
difficile à supporter chaleur bruit
odeurs le nouvel atelier est entièrement
ventilée naturellement la charge
physique a été diminuée par l'équipement
d'un ascenseur entièrement automatisé et
par l'utilisation de liaison radio
téléphone
les locaux sociaux vestiaires douches et
salle de repos tout neufs ont été
construits en fonction des souhaits du
personnel amené à travailler dans cette
unité de production durée pour le
directeur régional du travail
et de l'emploi cet exemple n'est pas
isolé midi pyrénées dans le peloton de
tête des régions faisant un louables
efforts dans l'amélioration des
conditions de travail et je pense que
midi pyrénées se situe à un niveau très
convenable qui ne peut être mesuré en
réalité que par les dossiers qui seront
transmis dans le cadre du fonds pour
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure des
opérations donné par branches nous avons
pour le moins de 3 il y à 190
entreprises qui ont fait des demandes
par ailleurs ont toutes ne sont pas
honorés mais enfin je pense que c'est un
un élan qui devrait aboutir à des
résultats tangibles